katarina versus steve's staff
let's see how it plays out on arena
i wonder if we're gonna see strog back
up like he did in the previous games
where we kind of lose 30 seconds to
movement alone which is still quite kind
of nice to see however he goes in a bit
harder be interesting to see what the
game plan is here
all right he's trying to do the os for
harry stone besides that right duck does
beat all options beat inductor
oh okay i mentioned it earlier it was a
lie the downfall 2 got beaten by the by
the low i lied i'm sorry
i thought it was just a bit too slow but
maybe you're right
i want to do the plus frames one
nice option select there from galander
just go to the dick jab i'm on two again
he's trying to get the plus frames going
good defense some strong eats the odd
hit but he's out of the wall
now he's in rage on yeah nice these are
the 333 galanda takes the first round
here right now
oh single hop kick doesn't commit that
would have been a nice launch there
yeah
that will crash down four three it's
really going to work out for galander
even if steve blocks it he cannot launch
gets the flow but not ready for the
combo
[Applause]
downpour three plus four there
opening those lows going into the jabs
oh okay
i don't know what the truth is anymore
not gonna have a nice magic four and get
a connotion it's very hard to do that
off a single uh magic four there and is
that gonna be a whiff punisher is i
think
that was actually his throw break there
i don't think he he meant to do that
ranger i think he meant to do a thorough
break that's very classified characters
one plus two three breaks
oh the albatross spin twice nice
interrupt their great low parry there
from this frog
that is something i'd like to see change
is that rage arts and rage drives
initiated by what would be a throw break
it's really challenging at times
lars has that same problem of course one
plus two oh that is the hard pick up
there off of flicker back to strong is
definitely ready today
four massages
down back three two down back two to
follow up look at this start here quite
strong
new harrier love colander's not that far
off from taking it back though yeah but
nice outside
the sonic fights again by stroke
is is it it wasn't just a thing early he
just has a read on it
uh all the time it wasn't just for and
it's gonna go to the wall yeah neither
four four three combo very nice into the
stomp
i'm actually too nice
there as well so that was useful getting
away
great location like a lander can't carry
off of the wall though
nice duck could have got more oh look at
that bad
okay rocket punch
yeah can uh just go too far but again
run up into back two i don't know what
he's looking for not gonna be the round
though qcs2 the plus frames nice block
and oh my goodness galanda puts
everything on that low
final round let's go girl under versus
strobe gollander doing far better than
he did in the last game playing out of
his skin
oh
kick we'll go into the wall as well go
for the max combos
perfect range for a max juggle
yeah just messes up at the end though
i'm back three two again and then he
gets the pick up this time that is not
easy to do
or doesn't double the second at four
four two
nice nice
but no not in the back but no punished
by galander the punished by strong
running two plus frames rocket punch
sonic
like that
oh what's he gonna do down for two
the lander in rage
they're quite cautious right now one
lord ends it for either of them in the
magic four by the land he's gonna take
the first game
that was a start
that was that was crazy good i mean it
was interesting what's what's trying to
look into strog's mind is what he was
doing uh when katarina had that rage in
the final round he was just trying to
lock her down and stop her from pressing
buttons at the wall but then when he
backed off did he go too passive maybe
it seemed like he just slowed down a bit
too much
i feel like what it started to cost him
as well is those those
random sonic fangs it worked before
against one so i was sitting there like
okay this is it but now it's like
yeah you've got a coyote especially
against karina we saw karine's punch for
it two two super good chunky plus frames
like it's it's not something you want to
mess with i feel like you need to go
back to using it on just the way punish
the way it's supposed to be used because
that was not
that was not uh fantastic to say the
least uh man is it's kind of what cost
in the game at the end of the day so
you've got to be a lot more careful
there so let's see um how he adapts that
stroke definitely isn't out right now
but we were seeing here why katherine
was is seen as such a good match against
steve the magic fours the lows going on
the downfall too i don't know if the
first time it happened it looked like it
went under but then he caught it the
second time so i just don't know um but
he switched to the lars
interesting very interesting
this is the character stroke initially
made his name with
over europe defeating all of the top
players i've known with the lars
let's see how it works here right now
um i i the thing is
i don't know if i agree with the switch
because you saw it was a final final
round final hit situation and he lost to
a magic four
you know that wasn't that wasn't like he
lost because of the character but lars
you're gonna have an easier time in this
matchup you're gonna have to play your
neutral a bit more you're gonna be able
to go under certain things so you know
it's it's not a bad decision
but maybe he could eat that with steve
let's find out great logo i agree with
you i agree with you like he also went
up forward four four a couple of times
right in the middle of the stage and a
lot a chunk of damage it wasn't like he
was ground down repeatedly over time
there were just some key moments
but still he's got the last great arc
class there
gonna put gallander in rage 1.4 great
block for the wall but the wall he still
could no he doesn't get oh no oh no so
on both sides very unfortunate uh the
race drive connected but didn't get the
sort of throw follow-up animation uh
because of the side wall and then i
think stroke just panicked because you
know i saw he expected galan to do
something in that situation the drop
expected to follow up went for the rage
shot um just panicked
look at that
absolute chunks flying air alexanderson
oh punish that could have had a lot more
there well the harrier sweep that's
something punish that
nice once again end with the art blast
can the wall mess him up though i don't
know if this is dead actually it is
round three
fight
he saw the last time galan did that did
the exact same fallout finish that low
committed and that was a reset colander
could have taken there and the wall
bounce do it again very nice
it's going to go low i knew it
down back we just have to in that
situation you know round four
fight
strong in the driving seat now
can only be using last for the rest of
this these next two games if it goes
that far i don't think he'll mind that
because lars is doing a good job right
now with punishment one point this is
the thing you can do with lars you can't
do with steve you can whiff punish with
launches you'll see it and do the art
blast there it is again that's something
that steve doesn't have the same luxury
forward stuff like his back too it's
just not as not as versatile
[Music]
and there we go
that is going to be it that is a very
dominant showing there from the last um
and just showing you know the characters
bearing the match up and one thing we're
seeing is just one thing strong is very
good at is with punishment uh but when
you play a character like last instead
of steve you can launch with your with
punishment steve's back to
his options for launching aren't the
same can really be used in the same way
but uh strong is really making use of
that last for the whip punishment
confident with punishment as well i mean
when you're playing again katarina and
you see in up forward four when it
whiffs there's a part of you
in your head that's thinking they're
going to continue it and i'm going to
eat the second hit but no he didn't even
think about it he just went for his art
blast straight away and took the damage
yeah and he played super strong his wall
his wall offense was very very strong
um it's looking tough for girlander now
i mean i wonder if glenda's going to
switch he's you said he's been playing
ganryu of late yeah when gary first came
out uh glenda was dumping a bunch of
time into the character character he
played away back in tag two as well so
um
he could go there
but i just i don't know it's not
necessary but i i'm not one to speak on
character switches because you know i
said he should have switched he switched
look what he did there so you know like
i said last is an easier time in the
match or better time with punishment so
let's see if that continues uh galando
maybe just a stage pick if i'm glad i
want maybe a smaller stage i think
because katarina really has found those
walls in play and a bigger stage only
benefits
switched dude let me finish my thought
though a bigger stage only benefits lars
because last is going to will carry
forever um regardless of the stage of
small or big um
so yeah but he's gone for again
he can carry you into tekken 8. but i've
noticed that
[Laughter]
can carry you into the west africa uh
qualifier tournament tomorrow now i've
noticed that there were a lot of lows
then i wonder if gallander is going to
make some reads and start ducking more
four four three four down back four
they're all being used quite a lot
blast again just getting struck so much
miles we're gonna get a sidewall here
nice ghost low gets the count hit
launcher catches galander's aggression
working against him but nice the back
comes through the head bar
punish that
over top
and down for three such a strong low
that gary has access to only minus two
but not the power crush guaranteed very
nice thereby actually that shoulder
wasn't guaranteed i don't think i think
the stomp is guaranteed
look at the movement here by strong and
that's the thing i mentioned earlier
that russian style is so good with the
timing that's why carrick's like steve
and lars do they they really have fun
with that character over there nice
stuck there and i like the option it's
very hard to punish
the back ones are working now look at
this start here by stroke the running
three three it's looking like strong and
lmg mobile on a collision course towards
each other right now all he needs is one
more round and it's looking likely
let's see what glenda has to say about
that he hasn't really been able to get
anything in yet and he needs to nice
head but not going to come with more ok
or if he peeled off the wall that could
have been it the ladder is beginning
i could say that in hindsight because it
didn't work out it just looked like gary
wasn't ready but
strog is just on point right now i mean
i i feel like